[Musik]
in den bergen suchte er sein glück
patrick stalder konnte es jeweils kaum
erwarten und dem fuß des piz beverin zu
fahren und mit seinem strahler freund
kristalle zu entdecken erklärt kann
[Musik]
sind toll wie die auf browsern ab und
die trainer mit dem stück einen und
heimat einer stelle kaum ein weil das
werkzeug einer tour beim abstieg
beschließt sein kollege walter hinderer
umzukehren
mir ist es wohl so unwohl und den
anzeigen patrick sonja pro also mehrere
schnittwunden
wie kann ich an ihm ab tobias horn und
sich gott in gang
als patrick stalder dieser stelle
erreicht ist es kurz vor 10 uhr
fertigungs packt wenn du so lange herz
ruft kristall hoffentlich zwischen
menschen der truck fördert sie 60 nun
herr laxey und der handwerklichkeit aber
dass auch zur sicherheit wenn über
durchlebten steinig die top-fahrer meter
distanz langsamer wachsen
jetzt muss ich die chance kam nach
rechts und links haben wir bei drei
meter breite war in mexiko ist ja nicht
weg und dank ok probiert rüber zu und du
hast dass das so klappt förmige
schiefergestein taktik und darüber ist
nicht ganz geschafft hat mich die jury
kann wieder abgerutscht da für uns
medici bei jenen unternehmen aber
kreiert
denn ich hier platter mehr auf pro
sturheit dem hauptweg schlager möchten
mit dem eine rückwärts auto der dritte
roman er nur gerührt und die
doppelbelegung die werster moment wieder
aus blut gespritzt und fingerte christus
zum gesicht geschossen
die haben aber auch gemerkt vom buchwert
bis zum haus käme dann eine einfache
spürte die lebensenergie zu der für
seine musik steinig rüstet sich für op
tisch jetzt fertig ist benito und mich
wieder für lkw nicht nach wien wies
punkte
denn es innerhalb sekunden komplett es
wurde dann ist es soweit
[Musik]
er hat aber mit kindlicher wunder also
wenn ich jetzt schon mal starten
denn worte wenigstens wüsste was jetzt
passiert ich gehe aber nicht vergabe das
wort dialog und dann wirklich mit der
letzte kraft und kann die kanoniere nur
im labor sondern kraftakt macht das ist
wahrscheinlich weniger strom bei kilo
gewichtheber wird oder irgendwas
verrücktes mit der größte kraft und ich
bin ganz allein auf braucht dann kann
ich denn da eigentlich auch probiert oft
politisch ein frei wählbares jetzt
passiert sekunden später hat sich der
großmarktkette die airline ab knapp und
den berliner mode luft flogen
die datacloud xiii willen ist das wie
soll ich dann sofort verschwunden
die hatten mich versehe ist etwa 15
meter vorhinein aber wir hatten auch
schließlich lienen gesehen dank sei dir
gut wenn es minivan den sknv bin ich
bestimmt glaube dass ich wieder schaute
sie begleitet worden ist verschwunden
der stein hat patrick stahl der den
brustkorb und die linke gesichtshälfte
zertrümmert der kann sich kaum im
steilen hang halten halten nicht
probiert überhaupt luft zu bewegen
vermag er im brustkorb es knapp noch
nicht zu fahren kann
da ich nach drei minuten immer noch eine
chance eigentlich kommt das gut an
[Musik]
sport ich bin ganz locker und ich haben
mit dem auto knapp also drop standort
gebilde königsee card und wer könnte
bewegung in not und mir die hand und das
paar samt gemähte weg schmerz ist
steigend jetzt verschwindet sondern
probiert mit becker zu bewegen
man grüßt ich bin nicht verlernt
niemand sieht oder hört den unfall
niemand wird patrick stahl dass
hilferufe auch zu hause wartet niemand
auf ihn nur sein freund walter und der
wirt will wissen wo er ist
ja intensiv als weiter beobachtet und
die haben mir schwerer lag hofft dass es
rum cola kostet es wenige stunden
trennen wenn sie stundenlang nackt bin
ich überzeugt sie hat ihm ein kollege
realisiert dass ich trotzdem recht so
kobi
ja schon seit kindertagen moment die
große flick
doch bereits am hauptbahnhof gehört und
christ die hauptstrecke die redmonder
zur freilassung
als nach zwei stunden neuer regen
einsetzt ist walter hinderer bereits auf
dem heimweg
sogar von einer vitrine stehen sich
gelöst wenn sich mir richtig bewegt
jack oft mit hochwertig sei der firma
bezahlen
das realisiert das werk das am sonntag
sieht und dann strom kommt eine zu
auch diese hoffnung erfüllt sich nicht
patrick stahl da liegt in den felsen
circa 80 meter unterhalb des wanderweges
links vom bach es ist pfingstsonntag
montag ist ein feiertag nach und nach
realisiert dass er voraussichtlich nicht
vor dienstag bei der arbeit vermisst
werden wird
das ist in zweieinhalb tagen sieht den
parkplatz wo sein auto steht und das
gasthaus wo am abend zuvor mit walter
eingekehrt ist
der ist bereits zuhause fand ich immer
sehr vorsichtig sie bei denen auch
schnell sein kann oder mit einer menge
anderer kurs diskutiert wie gut da meint
dazu und das dritte hohen patiniert
denkt ist um von 14 tagen audi selbst
stehen in der ufa und interniert denkt
aber nur verbote das ist so in gang
definiert denkt dass der hund im
rucksack wären warme kleider das handy
lebensmittel wasser doch er kann den
rucksack nicht erreichen
herr christ
das wären quarterbacks wer halt tag wird
müsse ohne wasser und frauen sich zwei
herr die nacht in den bergen mit nicht
nacht deutlich weiter geht müssen
überleben
wenn mir bewusst wurde dass ich nicht
nur die vorbereitung auf die nacht
jetzt können am leben
diana bade und rückgebaut geschoben und
nach der mit shift platte das ganze
abdeckt
mit der schäfer plötzlich drei
zentimeter auf dem ganzen oberkörper aus
streit wo man mit der mediation zu
erhalten
an diesem tag im mai war es kalt 5 grad
in der nacht werden die temperaturen
unter dem gefrierpunkt fall ist die
nacht wäre extrem härter unicef wird
sich 2242 strom vier stunden lang sei
die mutter nur und damit die nicht
verzweifle der nacht wenn wir einfach
keine chf 21 zeigt oberschenkel klopfte
und gleichzeitig der garten daniel 617
kilometer betrieblicher pro minute und
daniel und daniel berg seit das mache
ich denn wenn 14 14 im vorjahr big boss
sie ja ganz genau gewusst wie ich das da
über den bergen ist die andere leute die
vier zähler zum schlafen und ich kann
einfach nur zum wach blieben will nur
nicht ganz sache machen wo repetitiv
sind das heißt hier alle business user
finden wo mich die wachau und was paul
thomik schwach dass wenn ich nicht gern
machen würde das nervt mich
nein ich sage zählt fertig lea christ
schlafe gleich tot dass sich mini
glücklich sie wo mich die ganze nacht
natürlich beherrscht hat in dem sich
läufer gleich tot
ich habe mir alle minister und
konzentration zusammen zum juni die
schlaufe an die küsterin hatte keine
chance
denn hiv zähler und update an ideen aber
auch vor cfc pentke lautet und hanna
sofern aber gemacht aber nicht einfach
so locker rufen aber schnell sondern mit
kraft also wir haben die oberarme wie
linien 10 anzag wieder herrn datenhafen
mit sauerkraut zither und mit dabei so
hin und her machen dass sie einfach der
muskelbewegung hoch vor wärme dann
werden wir mal was sagen die career
bringen als dass sie nicht glück denn ja
morgen und ob das vechta art märz um
hilfe schreien ich extrem schmerzhaft
immer wieder heißt immer wieder jetzt
doch wer den schüttler hat das erklären
wir beruhigt nach irgendwie die
schüttelt wo sie höre ich am zelt jeder
art so jede minute zählt 40 minuten habe
ich wieder um hilfe
da war der sturm hilfeschrei sachse
bereits ich gelöst haben das nie
reagiert hat 78
eigentlich ein aussichtsloser situation
[Musik]
ich habe nie studiert und mit taktische
wahl der zug ohne patrick der wald ist
so richtig vor kälte gesehen ist der
eingang derzeit darum in dem patrick
rapp gemacht hätte und der patrick und
sport an gott sei bei den im moment
zahlen bevor es heißt bevor sondern den
sie immer neue bis klinikleiter es sei
bis jetzt haben sie auch mal ganze
geschäft wo vorbei war nicht mal selber
kochen hat irgend ein wenig fragen hätte
patrick passiert so etwas
erzählt unterziehen und sich morgen
morgen ist sturm noch mal durchstarten
vier mal anderthalb stunden und im hotel
stehen wenn es passiert ist sich oft mit
hard mit dabei gar nicht minute wieder
fahren müssen
rang unter druck setzen wenn ich gewusst
ich halte das waschen muss die marke
verstehen
nur eigentlich vorstellen oder dem
gefühl den drang wellen schlagen war
[Musik]
morgen hat schick sie erzählt lore
schmerz kammer und dabei das ist nicht
helmut fischer vergleichen sie das
morgen wird
mit der sonne strahlt sich das gefühl
von wärme stellt haben immer noch zäh
aber ich habe nicht so schnell müssen
uns bewusst sei es geschafft die hats
geschafft
aber bis der sommer und das ist nur
langen moment sie und wo ich dass ich
nur überraschend sie es werden immer
härter
es ist der held ist punkt ich noch dem
das drum hannover hund und ich bin
natürlich immer lockt sie mit glück
heute so morgen 7 jagdeo zone sowie
zwischen schiene und probierten der
athleten zu nichts geführt glaubt durch
ui werden aber die sonne hier natürlich
glück während also ja morgen genauso
klar wie der nacht daran ich bis jetzt
muss ich mir für die zeit nach
vorbereiten chance ist groß dass sie die
haustüre stand gelockt was wirklich
hanau kann zu den ab ca
handwerklich mini wunder wir hatten
alles kontrolliert aber klar die stein
klar dass höfe litauer das anders wie
viel liter andere das auch weniger
steinbruch gemacht und eine wieder der
ganztag das zug sortiert material
anprobiert lohr genau wie viel ich die
platte wo sie sinnlich regierbar 80
zimmern abgerutscht petra die größte die
steuer natur das mit isolationsmaterial
abhaut
als trinker dass ich ins ziel wo ständig
ein quartett und ja auch gemerkt dass
die kraft nehmen durch den körper
austrocknet lepper die hand nehmen
können ruft uhr zum seeufer pflege die
ing am montag das leben schwer gemacht
sie ist nur für sie vor dem wetter vom
recker und die verpflegung schwärmt also
dass ich mir sagen wie wir die sind ist
bloß der die ist dass alle diese
buchstäblich ist molina
also mein letzte zugang und in der luft
auch eine rolle
und das ist schon mehr als am 7
[Musik]
wenn tag ist schön wer taxi kann ich
besser gründertag von den vier mal haben
sie getrunken
woher nehme ich nur das wasser so
maschine zwar nicht entschieden
fawcetts brenzel der moment stelle
minute wäre müsse den nachweis einer und
sah dass der wind etwas lieblos ohne
dass schädliches am auge getroffen
chance dass ich den tag gerettet wird
und ich günstig klingt der auch immer
wieder antrat dank der rentierte mehr
stil erklärt
vom waren dabei hätte annehmen können
weil das was wir tun und der parkplatz
war sie von dort wohne axel heitmann der
parkplatz ganz groß oder patrick stahl
der liegt nun schon seit 30 stunden im
kalten hat es geschafft die ganze zeit
über wach zu bleiben sich zu
beschäftigen und den körper warm zu
halten
doch die kälte setzt dem immer mehr zu
am nachmittag des zweiten tages wird sie
unerträglich das gefühl kc landgang
[Musik]
kanada immer durch haben die beiden ein
fixpunkt vom blatt knot
welche bewegungen studiert
und die wollte ich und ich nicht weiter
kann man sich sein ticket man weiß ich
sekunde zwischen wirklich es doch längst
hat sich die woche wirklich kann dank
der simulation ich hatte nur um den
degradierten programmiert veränderung
nach drei stunden die tiere wohl genau
zeigt dass damit sie denn alles
realisiert dass die computeranimation
ist sondern die wirklich nehmen
ich kann tagen im stress kann der himmel
hundertmark zeit was ist realität dass
es werte und du bist da und das doppel
sind wirklich über wochen
bei einbruch der nacht ist patrick
stalder dem tode nahe
die halluzinationen deuten daraufhin
dass seine körpertemperatur auf circa 30
grad gesunken ist kühl sein körper
weiter ab kommt es bei 28 bis 27 grad
zur ohnmacht und darauf folgt der
herzstillstand
eigentlich werden die ärzte später sagen
kann man so etwas gar nicht überleben
[Musik]
wenn ein windstoß so schmerzhaft das
wird relativ verschmerzen
zickig und ich nicht vorlagen kommen
ich habe wäre müsste damit gerechnet
sie haben kontrolliert die schlaf
[Musik]
marisa merken viele autos wohl und
parkplatz stehen wohl länger stellen wo
zwei drei tage stand und es wenig bewegt
wird uns oder nachahmer morgen wird es
könnt sie das tor passiert ist das hat
man so immer wieder gemacht aber bei dem
jetzt dieses mal angebracht haupt nicht
weiß gar nicht warum nennen nicht
studiert in dem moment studiert ich weiß
nicht was das klingt höhere gewalt oder
weiß es noch nicht
[Musik]
sportlichen sozialen dienst audi nach
audi r8 wird lebendig sei die findet die
wallfahrt probierte verschiedene völker
jetzt finde wie es heißt handelt am
morgen hier und da einen jackpot nach
der sturm gott sondern muss angegangen
[Musik]
sturm nichts ohne umfang geschützt sie
total erschöpft und athletisch
vor allem die abdrücke sie kann forschen
im quest ihr sitz ist die chance da sie
kreditiert und morgen rund eines telefon
von der mama bei ihm und den kopf
geschossen
hye ja ja dass bestimmte bist passiert
walter telefonieren sagte walter
ich sagte patrick und der wald ist ganz
heiß auf sie und hätten dank sei dir ist
gelüftet
wo der bach über bochum mit der
badewanne 20 meter rechts und
ästhetischer praxis ein wenig los der
wanderweg richtung musik und hans graf
und gräfin und graf mit den einsteiger
gewiss es ist schon mal gehört haben
sich 15 6 uhr ein denken das ist jetzt
möglich dass es durch und bin aber
bestimmt 20 meter an ihm vorbeigelaufen
und hat nix
[Musik]
auf dem bergischen rief als metallurge
dass die besucher wenn ja wo ist walter
ganze nacht und tag und ich immer wieder
tore kriegt wird das verfahren sind
oktober nach partnern suchen kann
wie kommt es dass ich meine verletzungen
[Musik]
plötzlich
die moderatoren und ich höre dass chris
von august an wieder wachstum und wenn
ich das immer noch und was immer noch
wahrscheinlich die maschine
pilot andreas troge hat sich entschieden
zum wärmen das team so machen dort davon
danach über das klingt absurd und
mehreren darf s 8 bis s windig machen
sind dann ganz lang löste dank haifa
sind die ich sehe sie nicht abdankt ja
mariechen hat franz bork rocknight damit
sehe ich noch nie auf der haupt sehen
ich dir nicht und ruhm mache ich
überlege gemacht und da vor mir rufe und
das ist natürlich sehr sehr moment sei
es okay
20 meter weg vom meer und der treter
hello kitty
unternehmen trentiner bewegen kam immer
näher
das ist der einzige wo es wohl die
straff merckx am gemacht hat
verkleideter mehrin nicht von dort war
sehr schwierig sie das alles vor dem
schlamm und vor dem skiverband
schwarzwald svs aber die bewegung die
handys aufmerksam gemacht dass das laste
patrick simoner zur denkt da nicht bis
zum mixer und update ist natürlich von
arten entspannung
ruby als eine große veränderung ist nix
sie so im kampf wenig sie die kann man
einfach geschaut aber ja einfach
gewissheit k
jetzt schafft das ist schönes gefühl
[Musik]
natürlich sehr emotionales sie also sich
um steuern weist zwei tage steffen misst
ähnlichkeit ist wie möglich dass der
noch am leben ist
und da der geschichte bewegung und
theaterkarten sondern moment das ist die
niedrigste
wohnen in luxor ja ich es klasse dass
sie es können
weil der ich komplett trek xi wieder
boden oder wieder politischer komplett
drei fiktive personen durch luchsinger
beruf gemacht hat dass es wie sich drin
das ist einzig sie wohnen hersteller
erkennen und da der stimmen hat der
markt seit willy jetzt kunst wieso
grundstück rühren ich habe doch immer
größer hätte es mir erzählt an orten
still
alles war so der notarzt forderte
zentrales datum und verena hahn ist und
dass ich der willi bin dass er bei mir
übernachtet und verbiegt sie schon gar
nicht gewusst dass ein kunde heimtrainer
hannes telefon überhaupt gefunden
zehnjahressicht strommarkt transport ins
spital zu dann wird eine 300 mio
wo sich dass die nummer gesprochen ich
meinen auch immer wieder darauf
angesprochen weil wir ich dass sie und
da ist das möglich
das kennen wir es gibt medizinische
wunder um da die batterie kircheis davor
dass er so gut überstanden
also ich persönlich arbeite gut gestern
als es bis zu zwei tage
[Musik]
im helikopter setzt sich das staunen der
rapper fort obwohl patrick stahl der 50
stunden lang kälte und nässe ausgesetzt
war ist seine körpertemperatur nahezu
normal
im kantonsspital in chur wird der
überlebende vom piz beverin bereits
neugierig erwartet
[Musik]
das emery von patrick stahl das
brustkorb seit die wucht des steins der
rechte teil vom brustkorb wo man die
überprüft zum beispiel sehen da da da da
also ganz sicher jede europäische zwei
stück sogar auf der rechten seite den
fernbereich verlustfrei und
gebrochenheit dort oder dort oderbruch
und tags darauf die linke sieht noch
ganz vorne den rippen
also die dritte vierte fünfte rippe es
in sich auch prof
dasselbe beim schädel ja die nase weil
mehrere kleineren größere buch stücke
zerborsten
und auch hier das mittel gesicht was
iris das nasenbein was eigentlich schön
gerade die in das gesicht gehört dann
hier das mittel gesicht und auch das ist
nicht nur hier sozusagen hinter der
wange und unter dem auge hier gebrauchen
oberhalb der zähne sondern auch auf der
seite von gesicht dieses größere
bruchstück da vom joch bogen das ist
hier alles abgebrochen schädeldecke und
gehirn blieben unverletzt
das ermöglichte es platte gestalter zu
überlegen doch wie schafft er es trotz
der kälte 50 stunden lang wach zu
bleiben
die frage stellt sich auch das
pflegepersonal
er hätte gerne noch mehr erzählt wie er
sich eigentlich im recht erhalten hat
mit der wärme nicht gefühlt dass ich
immer noch in den exit ganze ist aber
einfach sehr verkrampft wirkt das ganze
dass ich noch völlig voll präsent
wir wenden das nur indem es die macher
ich glaube nicht dass das bei uns oder
der selbst merkt aber das ist richtig
dieses bild entstand zehn tage nach dem
unfall
daneben ein bild aus unbeschwerten
zeiten bruchteil hat ein riesen
redeschwall krah und hat mir die ganze
geschichte zählt ins letzte detail weil
ich mir das auch im bett als cool und
eine tragende und dennoch nicht merkt
jetzt jetzt holt sie ihn wie ein
beispiel zeigt ja aber was sind denn die
emotionen plötzlich vor ihm sind
angestellt wo er stets platz über und
wie leben wir sondern ich fast das
abitur gekostet
auf anraten des seelsorgers und
psychologen beginnt patrick stelter
damit seine geschichte auf band zu
sprechen
insgesamt 22 mal nimmt er seine
geschichte auf immerzu erzählt dass sie
bis jetzt letzte detail so versuchte er
das geschehene zu verarbeiten
die art und weise wie er am berg
überlebte fasziniert die leute dass das
wahrscheinlich nicht getan kann ich sie
das was sie dachte jetzt dem tod ganz
bewusst in torgelow gewinnen und das ist
schon ein spezielles in der situation
war es wirke lebensgefährlich ist zu
tage die wir uns wünschen
denn will es ganz bewusst will das ganz
bewusst dass entscheidungsstrukturen
klick spruch
alles passieren und es war noch
schlimmer ist sie alle die ihr
sogenannter zufall
alles das hätte dazu geführt dass am
schluss endet plaudert ist wird land ist
so gelandet ist und interpretierten das
ja so dass sie dass sie wieder aber
nicht am nordwall immer möglich ist
sondern immer wieder lösungsorientiert
schafft das ding hat im koffer die
halterin konform zum wirklich alles
machen
die eiswiese glück kam dass ich will es
wissen kann christoph schaaf am doppel
bgh comes papier zwischen leben und tod
nicht gäbe hätten wir das natürlich
irgendwie mit angst kno das heißt ja der
tod akzeptiert kein anderer stelle und
du hast eine wie beide optionen kannte
das dass ich natürlich wahl eigentlich
kann hat das wiener neutrale stimmigen
absolut die ruhe die meere in mexiko
wollen natürlich klar 7 und von der
strategie her sehr aktiv ist ein enormer
ruhe also schon fast meditative ruhe
mehr ins exil wo sie steht der 3
und ja die schlimmsten schmerzen die ihr
anblick probe auf der spital in chur
folgt die rehabilitation in baden danach
kommt dann nach rheinfelden in eine
klinik wo die seelischen schäden des
unfalls therapiert werden fünf monate
nach dem unfall ist er wieder zu hause
in beinwil er läuft stunden lang und den
hallwilersee in dieser zeit zerbricht
seine langjährige beziehung
es kann überhaupt
es war einfach zeit 20 prozent und das
ist sehr schwierig also mit extremen
gefühle gedanken und scott irgendwie den
weniger verstehe gar nicht mehr darüber
geredet
es bleibt einfach ihre männer das ist
das geheimnis
schon bald nimmt er seine arbeit als
informatiker wieder auf dennoch nur zu
50 prozent
daneben arbeitete er an der
veröffentlichung eines erlebnis
berichtet er konfrontiert sich
unaufhörlich mit dem erlebten und kehrt
ein halbes jahr nach dem unfall zurück
an den piz beverin
[Musik]
zuerst einmal bin ich ganz bewusst im
herbst angegangen und zwar dass sie
krank stufe wenn die angst und iraner
beiden hat laut anklage mit dem messer
ungarn der lösungssuche aber leider
nicht wählen das hauptziel über den
winter einen anstoß bau wohl nicht real
ist und darum bin ich gerne und haben
mit dem konfrontiert
patrick ist plan lang im spital sind und
noch ist er den autounfall seinen titel
kommt aber ziemlich viel viel mehr ruhig
wie früher und ohne wenn er langsam und
so den job märkte so schweres private
dort machte
ja und dann hat er immer wieder gesagt
gott einmal die tufa coworker aber er
will allein gott hat new economy tarif
im alleingang ökologen zum normalen der
materie haben wir dann verzichte ich
immer wieder zurück und der gott nicht
ich muss sagen dass man nochmal
probieren hätten noch geschlafen und hat
weder das im laptop um das buch
schreiben und irgendwas
aber wie ich irgendwie so danny hörbe
jordanier waren ob miete
ein jahr nach dem unfall veröffentlicht
patrick stalder
im eigenverlag sein buch es heißt die
roten engel in anspielung auf die
rettungsflugwacht seine rhetorik und
willi sind auch da es geht patrick er
hat weniger schmerzen
auch das trauma scheint überwunden
[Musik]
anderthalb jahre nach dem unfall muss er
sich in chur die metallplatten aus dem
gesicht entfernen lassen
und da holte ihn alles wieder ein wo
mehr das metall im verantworten
ich bin ich natürlich im bett sie also
ein gleiches zimmer gleich ins bett und
wo es mir das musiknoten 1 marian naase
mister brechen und so zeugs und das ist
natürlich wie das liquid oben am berg
ich bin um maxi ich habe wenig luft
überholen
russischen ufa die haben dann auch im
bett so planer höhe rourke niederlage im
spitalbett oben am berg der rega heli
ist zu 100 im spital und gang durch das
fenster auf dauer zu machen aber wo der
sauerstoff ak zwischenzeitlich fror das
hat alles noch niedriger
bis mir wieder fit ist muss oder dass
anders b
und da bin ich den weg in umbau
zurückkehrt und im panico
[Musik]
stiege zum beispiel die garage das auto
von red rose macht passt dann frontal im
gesicht
das problem ist wenn ich dann tust du da
kann ich die bilder reaktor aber im
dunkel ist weniger was vor allem ist
wenn es stress im alltag geschaffen und
so weiter denn auch nicht weniger
aber wenn ich zum beispiel ferien und
wirklich entspannen
doch und halt einfach sondern bewusst
sie denn also falls du sie einer nacht
100 150 mal der steiger hob 4
und dennoch hat einfach die augen auf
und ethisch einfach der fehler ist dass
sie muss ich sagen klar hätte
schlimmeres so dass das ereignis weniger
ich dass mir der steine frontal ich ob
wir sondern er hat jedes mal den augen
für die tiefsee womit der platte
verdrückte er und die band im psycho
mack locker sind und dass ich blutarmut
sehen sein da ganz rumpf also zusammen
presst amfar ist und ich danke basierend
auf dem hang zum teil natürlich problem
obwohl die strahlen-lecks ib und die
kristalline mit platzangst und zwar das
entkleiden
das problem sie haben es als unter liebe
ja es ist wahr ich habe geschwitzt
die probier sagt sie die chefs nicht ich
komme mit platzangst ihr ja schon für
sich 2005 leider messe verschiedene
einfach meter schärfen körper schmiede
will ich nicht geschafft haben schnell
genug osteiner hof und in panik
drei jahre nach dem unfall ist patrick
stalder zurück im leben
er hat eine neue liebe gefunden die
körperlichen schmerzen aber sind
geblieben und auch das trauma ist
weiterhin da
[Musik]
er kehrt nun schon zum fünften mal zu
rückgang den piz beverin
ich probiere jetzt ganz bewusst auge
möglichst wenig zur tour will also ich
meine letzte feld passiert das in der
nacht aufgewacht und da jedes mal der
felsen hocker und ich denke das würde
jetzt passiere moment aber ich probiere
es ganz bewusst die pflanze im
hintergrund ruft zugenommen der ort
service schönes machen der ortsverbände
meter meinen teil von batterien und
nicht - low cost dobernig mini lag sie
ihre eigentliche uva
bisherige träger und ohne frankreich
vivendi nach rechts ab und will ihn
jetzt stade hang abzüge wenden der
ohnehin schon irgendwo legte prof
der lebenswille den patrick stalder in
den felsen des piz beverin bewies hat
ihn zu einem gefragten ratgeber gemacht
seine geschichte macht mut und hilft
betroffenen mit schicksalsschlägen
fertig zu werden
das gibt ihm kraft für sein neues leben
kann ich einen fehler mache
bruchteile davon nach wie vor schmerzen
wieder muskuläre hat irgendwie einfach
das ist so gar nicht der wenig schlaf
der blogs mir natürlich das ist klar
wir haben der linken gesichtshälfte
fühle
wir haben eine extreme tinnitus also
leute ist dass ich jetzt weiter
das sind die negativen sachen unschöne
ich jetzt wirklich mit wasser könne
passieren da am werk wenn ich eigentlich
die glückwünsche von der schweiz glück
nicht
[Musik]
der center